hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
i have a review for you today and that
is of this uh
kef ls50 meta uh
passive speaker um it retails for about
fifteen hundred dollars a pair so not
cheap for a
two-way speaker so the hope is that it
performs
great at that price uh i must say it's a
gorgeous looking
uh small speaker you can see it sitting
over here
and a nicer picture in the frame
um this uh coaxial uh
uh driver by kef is is a work of art as
far as just natural beauty by itself and
then once you put it in this
beautifully made uh composite uh case
it just looks stunning um you know i
think
many people would just buy this as art
and put it on shelves
instead of actually listening to it it
would have almost as much value
even the back end of it is pretty in the
work that they've done in integrating
the uh
port in there you know it's offset it's
custom molded everything
uh the um love the banana
or multi-way uh uh speaker jacks uh
they're really nicely done and easy to
tighten and untighten
i like the wider distance between them
than than what some of them use where
you can't get your fingers in between
them
um the cabinet feels very strong and
very dense which is
always good um so uh
you know our business is to know
reliably how the speaker performs and
for that i use this
quibble near field scanner this is a
robotic machine where you can tell it to
basically scan a speaker 360 degrees
around
and then computationally you can create
uh the uh solve the equations that
describe the sound field from a speaker
as it radiates
so you can then tell what the sound is
like at any distance
and the measurements are made near field
uh meaning that
the microphones are close to the speaker
and the advantage of that is that the
sound is much stronger than the noise
so you can make measurements anywhere
you don't need an anechoic chamber
and then when it generates these results
it's actually more accurate than
than having an anechoic chamber i
usually use about a thousand measurement
points that takes about two and a half
hours
um it's directly proportional to this
number so if you make it
two thousand points it takes four and a
half five hours just for the
measurements
and then it takes at this setting about
20 minutes computationally to uh
for it to do the math and figure out the
sound field if you make it
more than that it takes even longer the
system is self-reporting in that
uh it actually makes some specific
measurements in space and then it
computes them from near field
and compares the error between the two
um
with this speaker and many uh speakers
1000 points
is good enough and it was especially
good enough because the speaker has a
very clean response the more complex the
the sound field is it has a lot of you
know jacket
and deformities in it the
more points you need and the fact that
this doesn't need it means it's a
good good measuring speaker as you'll
see in a second
so the heart of our measurements is this
thing we call the spinorama
it's a term that comes from harman and
research that they did and prior to that
national research council in canada dr
floyd toole and his team
and basically it's a collection of
curves uh the most important one of them
is this black curve over here that says
the on-axis sound that's the sound that
directly comes from the speaker and
points at you
and unless speaker manufacturer tells
you otherwise and they really know what
they're doing
that's the way you should point the
speakers point them at your face that's
the best sound of the speaker
is what comes at you on axis and what we
like to see ideally is something looks
like that blue line
so we're not seeing that but what is
there for speakers
is quite good uh certainly down here is
this little bit of deviation is not
consequential around crossover we get a
little bit
you know a few notches here and there
and a little bit of modulation here
and then it once a tweeter takes over
it then becomes very smooth and very
controlled
and uh basically if you get that right
60 chance the speaker is very good
that's your first order elimination
speaker that screws up on axis you could
just put a side chance of it sounding
good it's
very very low and and it's basically
coloring everything
your ear uses the on axis the first
sound as the most important
sound to uh establish to analogy of
speaker so we want that to be right
but we also wanted the reflections from
speaker that hit all the walls and come
back at your
walls and ceiling and floor we also want
that to have similar tonality it doesn't
have to be identical but it needs to
have similar tonality
and when the two are the same then it's
a homogeneous
sound how much of the reflections mixed
with direct sound is not as important
because
they both mix into the similar kind of
tonality and so
we call that directivity and the
directivity is the
next filter for you you want to look at
on axis that gets rid of a lot of bad
speakers and then if the activity is
good
way up there as far as probability of of
a good sounding speaker that many people
will like
and the ls50 gets there as well these
other curves like this one dash one for
example
in blue is the uh the most important the
most
loudest the most the loudest reflections
uh from ceiling floor and and
immediate walls are summed together with
a weighted average and and you get this
blue curve and if you compare this blue
curve
to the black curve they look pretty
similar you can actually see that
comparison down here
and you can see that line's very smooth
i could almost draw a line through it
it's okay for it to tilt up that means
your off axis has less highs in it
that's okay because the tweeter starts
to beam and narrow
a little bit and that's fine uh to get
some amount of that because
you actually want to see that so this is
very good directivity
um i will come back to more of this spin
information but i also do another test
which is uh
i take the microphone and i point it
very close to the driver
if there's multiple drivers there are
multiple drivers i
do it for each driver here's just
squawks who also i
measured both and then a point one to
the back where the port is
and measure them independently so we can
see what each one of them more or less
is doing i can't shut off the drivers
without tearing up part of the speaker
but this gives us an approximation
we see the port in the back and we see
that it nicely augments the on-axis
response
i mean the main drive response which is
nice and um
the only issue i saw in here was this
peaking over here this looks like the
woofer is
going down as it should and then twitter
is taking over but somehow there's
something above
zero uh you know what they should be
neutral
and without being able to separate the
two drivers i can't tell if it's the
woofer that's starting to do some crazy
things
that causes that or the tweeter likely
is the woofer
um that's a bit of bad news the good
news is that what
comes out of the port in the back is
very low in the amplitude and
very well behaved on many speakers that
i measure especially the ones that are
not well engineered this peak is first
of all
here where the drivers are much more
vulnerable as
because their levels are coming and then
they actually come up and kiss these
graphs in some cases you can go higher
whenever they do that you basically
hearing resonance is internal to the
speaker which is not something you want
to have
get out and here we have many decibels
of separation
so some really good absorption inside
and compute
computational modeling has been done by
kef and designed to be able to keep
these resonances inside the cabinet very
very controlled and at the right
frequencies and so forth so
another good sign that you know kev's
done the right job
as i mentioned that blue graph in the
spin data we have a set of reflections
that are the most powerful
the other reflections are less powerful
meaning let's say it
hits the right wall then it hits the
back well then it comes at you
by time it gets you the levels are very
low so we care mostly about what these
immediate surfaces are
and i've drawn a line through the what
you want and the green curve
is is our total
sum of all those reflections and we see
that it
more or less matches that it has the
same little bit of wiggliness in the
middle that
you know perfect speaker wouldn't have
but otherwise the two are similar
and that's why we're getting this you
know good directivity
we'll come back to directive deal later
um
there's been research done by harman in
correlating and computing what a
predicted in-room response would look
like
based on the first two measurements all
the measurements i've shown you are
anechoic meaning that they assume no
room
no reflections at all but we're
interested in sound of a room
someone was speaking in a real room so
statistical models been developed
what you know rooms more or less look
like and that's where the
these reflections come from if we take
these and someone with special form
formula with the on axis we get a single
graph that says look
likely if you put this speaker in a
typical room
you're going to get this kind of
response we always want to tilting down
and we're getting that and we want least
amount of variations from
from this line so again this little mid
region has a little bit of
imperfections in there and i'll try to
quantify these when i
get to my listening test section but
otherwise this is the kind of curve we
want to see
as a note uh studio monitors are
designed for professional applications
tend to have a flatter line they believe
in having
do nothing that that's different both on
and off axis
and that's fine too i find them
enjoyable just as well but from
typical hi-fi listening you tend to want
to have this sloping down to have a
little bit less highs
than you would otherwise uh on this
thing
so we now get more of drill down into
directivity and
here basically we're plotting every 6 db
drop in amplitude in a horizontal
axis so well look at the speaker and i
go left and i go right
and just show you 6 db drop-offs what
does that look like and what we want to
see is a stack
of these curves that looks similar and
but more importantly the red one which
is the minus
60b one we want to see that as sort of
uh
um as flat as we can get it
that means the directivity is uniform
and controlled the speaker isn't getting
wider than narrower than wider
when it does that the frequency response
is changing off axis and
you don't want that so this kevlus fix
50 meter has
very good control of that there's a
little bit of cost to that in that when
you control that oftentimes the angle
gets small
and it is a bit small horizontally at
plus or minus 50 degrees so
you want to again point these speakers
at you you have basically plus 50
degrees minus 50 degrees that's good any
more than that then
you're gonna lose fair amount of your
energy in the higher frequencies
so not a bad trade-off at all but just
be mindful of that
same graph can be plotted with a lot
more resolution and then color coded
this is
really this graph is the same as this
one and we can see it visually it may be
easier that
you know where the sound energy is going
it's just basically it's just funneling
towards you
at a very controlled manner now
typically two-way speakers with the
twitter and woofer horizontally they can
get you pretty graphs like this but
vertically they tend to be atrocious in
that as you move up and down
the distance from the measurement
microphone in your ear
changes if the twitter's up here and
woofers in here and how the two mix
will change so you wind up having a very
erratic and torn up
vertical directivity coaxial drivers
don't have that problem because the
twitter is in the middle of the woofers
or whether you
deviate horizontally or deviate
vertically you get the same measurement
and so they do superbly in here but at
the same time know that
the science for horizontal dispersion of
directivity being good
is very strong vertically we tend to not
be that picky about it
in my room i also have a thick rug on
the floor anyway so the
floor bounce is not there and i have
high ceilings so
it's not as material for me but hey it's
been a goodness
if you take it it comes for free in a
coaxial driver
a new measurement i've been showing as i
mentioned the
clippable and near field scanner
computes a full 3d
sound field for the speaker so i can ask
it to give me
what the entire sound field looks in
at any frequency and i've chosen to show
that to you at a
thousand hertz two thousand hertz and
three thousand hertz sort of the
critical
some uh mid to upper frequencies and
uh you know an ideal speaker would
either look like a globe or
or oval we don't get that we get you
know wiggliness in here
since i've started doing this the first
few speakers i did them on
they were really really deformed so what
you want to see here as smooth and as
globe looking or overlooking shape as
you can get
you can see how good this one more or
less is a little bit out of
whack in here here you can actually see
it much better at 3 000 earth's
just a nice shaft of energy pointing out
here nothing from up nothing from top
and not much us
at the back if we had strong
diffractions
corners were sharp and radiating or you
know strange things happening
you would have you know uh deformations
up here you would have red up here and
so forth so this is
very very well behaved on this thing
distortion kef advertises that the meta
version of ls50
actually has lower distortion
unfortunately when i measured my
original
ls50 i uh didn't make the measurements
as good as i'm making them so i can't
compare the two
um what's there is is quite good below
200 hertz
uh above 200 i'm sorry about 200 shares
is very good i have this threshold i
drive 50
uh decibels and you can see above 200
hertz
distortion is very low and it just drops
off the chart down here
at uh 86 db spl
at 96 it's clearly getting uh unhappy
uh and so this is not a loud playing uh
speaker and i'll get to that when i talk
about listening tests these graphs you
can interpret them and get a rough idea
but
getting a precise idea the air works a
lot better when it comes to this kind of
distortion
impedances is low two-way speakers or
modern speakers in general they're all
around four ohms or so
this one drops to 3.7 ohm and it stays
3.7 ohm for this whole
broad region between roughly 120 hertz
and
600 hertz so a lot of the base energy
were
a lot of volumes in the music lands in
this area
and uh it's gonna strain your uh
uh your amplifier the other thing is
gonna strain it is that if we
go back to in here is the sensitivity of
the speaker
this is around 83 db sensitivity uh
you know usually i like to see 86 db as
an
average you know low sensitivity speaker
so this is not an efficient speaker
you tend to get more accuracy if you can
bring levels down
in the speaker and the compromises are
made to get accuracy but you lose
some volume playback capabilities so
know that you need
good powerful amplifier with a lot of
water don't think it's a small speaker
you can drive it with a 30 watt
amplifier it'll produce good volume for
you know bit as soon as you turn it up
you know
you're out of juice i'll use a 1000 watt
amplifier just to give you an
idea so that way i know my amplifier is
never the limitation
it's you know if something sounds
distorted you know based on volume then
it's because of the speaker yeah i'm not
a fan of time domain displays
but people want to see them so i've
shown them in here
so but just quickly look at looking at
it wherever you see these lines
extending it means you have resonances
but if you also look up here in the
frequency response whenever there is a
resonance and here usually is a
peak over here anyway and you could have
guessed that there were going to be
resonances there
but you know people like to look at the
pretty 3d graphs and there it is
now let me get to the listening test i
um
i have a set of tracks that i use for
evaluating both headphones and speakers
i always use the same tracks i always
start with i should say i always start
with the same tracks
and the first 10 tracks are so religious
basically i listen to them i know what
spots in them
cause what and um
i must have listened to them thousands
of times there used to be
music i like knives music i hate because
i listen to it so
much but anyway it's important to listen
to the same track all the time for years
at least have a chance of getting
calibrated to what they should sound
like
and usually on the first track that i'm
it's a female
vocal that i like to use and if the
speaker is good
when i listen to the first strike i'm 90
there and assessing
you know the sound of the speaker um but
we gotta verify
so on this speaker it just sounded
wonderful uh
you know i'm sitting there i'm done
basically you know i could just listen
to it
and and enjoy it but um
uh we want to verify that uh the the
measurements
said it would be a great speaker i might
listen to us or agree with it but we
still want to verify
that uh you know the what the effect of
these things are
are these frequency response errors a
problem or not a problem
so i've created an eq just to fill this
hole
take this bottom and bring it up here so
it's flat
and to do that it's such a narrow filter
i had to use a parametric eq with a q
of i think eight or something like that
seven or eight
uh at first i created it with a key of
four or five
and that means that it it raised the
levels from here all the way to here and
that had an effect but by the time i
tuned it so that it was just this whole
i mean there was a subtle effect that if
you recorded them and had me doing a b
test on abx tests i'm sure i could tell
the difference
but you know as far as general tonality
of the speaker
it just simply was not consequential it
wasn't even worth the
effort for me to capture it and put it
in the review
so uh you know it doesn't need
equalization from that point of view
and this basically the reason for that
is that our auditory uh
filters that we use in our hearing their
bandwidth
starts to get wider in that so
essentially they're averaging big chunks
of the spectrum
they're not like a spectrum analyzer
like
this measurement is and it can't it can
you know it basically can't distinguish
much again probably a little bit of
tuning you could do
i wrote in the review if you've got time
and these are speakers you're going to
live with
you know you could develop a little bit
of eq and you know pull this whole
region up and
maybe all of them combine four or five
filters would make a subtle
improvement um so the measurements are
speaking the truth uh
you know a little bit in here but in
grand scheme of things
you know it's a speaker you sit back and
listen to it
so i i listened to it and and it sounded
quite good and i was ready to just give
the star rating to this um
turned up the volume i at first it
handled it very well the
kind of music i was listening to was
sort of jazz and
and that sort of instrumentation on
vocals
it handled them very well i only test
with one speaker because our hearing is
much more
has much better acuity when it comes to
detecting tonal characteristics of the
speaker when you listen to one speaker
and so i'm listening to the one speaker
and
it's able to fill a large room with very
good volume
and um and so i was very pleased with it
one thing you can tell is that that
little woofer because it's reflective
you can see it from pretty far when it's
vibrating and when
it moves it actually separates from the
twitter that's in the middle
because there are two separate drivers
and it's sort of a little disconcerting
when you see that gap
in there but anyway you have a good
visual indication from many feet away or
how much this thing
is working on like a black you know
woofer this one you can see it move
and when it moves just a hair things are
okay the moment i played anything with
deep bass and i could see it move a
little bit more where it went beyond
vibration to actual movement
i could tell the tonality of bass
changed
turn it up a little bit more the
tonality changes even more
and one click past that and it crackles
scary crackle i'll let it crackle for
just a second and it's one of those
things where
you know you think your world's come to
an end luckily the speakers are very
robust and the cracker comes from the
fact that it just
comes at the windy comes out of the
magnet just enough and it just snaps
back
and so
there is a price to be paid for a
coaxial driver
this small it can only move that much
air
it plays cleanly so you tend to want to
turn it up
and you get it to that clipping point
where it just goes crazy
um it gives you some warning in that the
bass tonality changes the deep
tones that i was hearing they start to
get lighter in characteristics because
harmonic distortions of the bass
uh at higher frequencies so the tonality
of the bass
becomes higher pitching nation in nature
instead of
puppies sort of i don't know i can't
make the sounds but anyway
it's a good thing by the way if you want
to learn to be a good listener
find the worst case situation and turn
it down you can hear
that effect a lot better than going up
so with with this distortion if you turn
it up before it crackles
and then listen to the bass and then you
lower the volume
that change is much more pronounced and
you can
just easily first you can hear the
artifacts at that
you know loud volume with no placebo no
doubt you're hearing it you're at the
limit
you know you're at the limit because
it's just not happy
and then you gradually lower the volume
and you can see how it exponentially
drops off and
and then also the sound is fine and then
further reduction in volume
doesn't improve fidelity so you know
you're at the limit and what that limit
sounds like
you bring it down so um
i would be happy with these for you know
everyday
use as is um there's enough bass there
enough volume and if you put two of them
in a room
you know i only had one it gets even
louder but it is your
the only speakers you have and this is
all you have it for
then a subwoofer is definitely advised
uh
that's kind of warms and how you
integrate it with something like this
if you have an avr with automatic eq
that's one way to do it otherwise
manual process will require work and
setting up the crossovers and everything
but it needs some relief but uh again
for everyday you were used
you know it's a secondary room or if
it's your primary system but you don't
turn it up very loud
i think it's full range enough to enjoy
a lot of music and
not feel like you know you you need to
get a subwoofer
there are two-way speakers i test that
just fall apart so fast or they lack so
much bass that
you know you have to have a subwoofer
and i don't like those speakers at all
so where does this net out at low
to medium to even medium loud volumes is
exceptionally good speaker you'd have a
hard time getting a
better speaker lens way on top it's just
that when you turn it up
it's gonna fall apart and and so it
depends on your expectations
if you're never gonna turn it up that
much you never want the floor to rattle
and move under you and you feel the
music
physically then these are extremely good
speakers
gorgeously built you know from a great
company
and you know get it i was not a fan of
original ls50 its measurements are far
worse than this
and i never liked the sound either um
even though so many people loved it i
think they were just
looked at the look of it and like that
more than sound or they're not skilled
in
in in listening to speakers i don't know
but uh
it's just so nice to see that you know
kev recognizes it and and you know came
up with this i think i have the original
ls50s here do i have a link to it
uh no give me one second
no i guess i can't find it quickly
anyway the original ls50
review is also here and uh you can go
look that up
you'll see that the frequency response
went up and down i mean it was just
nothing like what i expected kef to be
producing
i was very surprised how poor that's
frequency response was it wasn't just
that too much highs or too much loads or
anything it just literally was wavy
going up and down
so it's very nice to see them improve it
14 1500 is a lot of money though so you
know you do have to make a decision
uh whether you like that or not okay
so hopefully you found this review
useful i enjoyed my time with it i'll be
uh
sad to be sending it back and
see you in a future review and video bye